- You got it wrong.
- I've got it wrong?
- So wrong. You have to look at the effect
on the banking industry,
as well as the auto industry,
- Okay.
- my friend.
- Listen.
- When you do,
- The bottom line,
- No, the only conclusion,
- the bottom line
- [Both] is that Obama is a disaster.
- [Both] Are you a Republican?
(upbeat music)
- Now first,
Let me just say that I'm
encouraged that so many of you
from the Republican Party have agreed
to meet me in this way.
Well, as you know, I've tried very hard
to reach across the aisle,
and govern this country from the middle.
- Well, all due respect, Mr. President,
we disagree with you.
- We think you should
run the country from,
not the middle.
- Well, That's why we're here.
If you would, I just
appreciate some feedback
on some new ideas and
directions for this country.
Feel free to agree or
disagree, whatever you want.
- We're going to disagree.
(politicians laugh)
- Yep, disagree.
- Disagree, disagree.
- [Politician] Disagree.
- First, I think the
government is too big.
I think we need to shrink
the size of the federal government,
so that all decisions can
be made at the state level.
- We disagree, Mr. President.
- You drive a hard bargain, You win.
(politicians laugh)
- There we go.
- Big government it is.
Next up. This has been a hot button issue,
but I think we can settle it right here.
No taxes for rich people.
- We completely disagree.
- Round two goes to you guys.
(politician laughs nervously)
- More taxes for the rich.
- What, What the (beep)?
- What is happening to us?
- Man I am taking a beating here, guys.
All right, last issue. Immigration.
Now we need to secure
our borders and anybody,
who's here illegally should
be hunted down and deported.
(politician stutters)
- We disagree!
(table thuds)
(paper crumpling)
(politician groans)
(tape rips)
- We are a country of immigrants! No!
- We need a clear path to citizenship
for all of those who are already here.
(Gasps) Help me!
(elder politician groans)
(scissors snipping)
(politicians groaning)
(table thuds)
- Great. I love your ideas.
Lastly, we can not regulate firearms.
- Yes we can!
- [Politicians] Yes we can!
- (politicians crying)
- Alright, alright. If you guys say so.
(politicians bawling)
And nobody better throw me a cigarette.
(wind whooshes)
- Ain't I a stinker?
(smile twinkles)
(engine humming)
- Wasn't that the turn
for our polling station?
- Uh, Why no young man.
Uh, see, we, we know a
shorter route to your uh,
to our democratic polling station.
- You know how us
Democrats like a shortcut
like, government spending
to prop up the economy.
- Nothing more than we
love than those, uh,
federal programs.
- You two are Democrats, Aren't you?
- What?
(both laughs)
- Of course we are.
- You see the color of
our skin, don't you?
How can we not blindly vote democratic?
- I mean, that would be ridiculous.
- Whatever. All I know is my polling place
close in 15 minutes.
- Why, why, that would be terrible.
- Awful. I mean, how are
you going to elect taxes
and spend politicians if you can't vote.
- It's hard enough to vote
with all those, voter ID laws,
- Republicans.
(both groans)
- Those, gosh darn Republicans.
- I know I'm just like, (growls)!
Yeah, you tell it too, Douglas.
- Right.
- You, uh, You know what?
If, if there were any Republicans here?
Whoa, I'd be pissed.
- Hmm.
- I'd be royally pissed!
- Me too, me too,
- In fact, I would take
their hard fought principles,
and I'd shove it right up their keisters.
(Douglas whispers indistinctly)
- We seem to be driving in circles.
- Don't worry. We're almost there.
(brakes screech)
(Man thuds)
- Huh. It appears we've hit somebody.
We should get out and help him.
(man screams)
- Heave ho.
- Oh my leg. Oh, my leg.
- Oh, oh
(man groans)
- Hold it. There you go.
- I am pissed.
- What?
- I'm royally pissed.
Now, although it was only
this one man's fault.
I will be using all of y'all
tax dollars to get healthy.
Thanks to the Affordable Healthcare act.
I know it doesn't seem fair,
but that's supposedly the
law of the land down here.
- That, that's what I heard.
- You don't look that hurt.
- Why are you wearing
those same leather jackets?
And those dad jeans.
- Disperse!
(men scuttle)
(sticker rips)
(woman gasps)
- Black republican mother(beeps)!
(upbeat music)
(man laughing)
(man shouts)
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Men] Dunk the vote!
- This November, you
got to get out and vote!
- It's all about democracy y'all.
Your vote gets counted with the rest
of the votes in the country,
and they get sent off to
the Electoral College.
- What's that?
- The electoral college
are a bunch of officials,
who'd do the voting for us.
So in case we elect the wrong person,
They can fix that shiz.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Hold up.
Who the hell are these people?
- Well, no one knows for sure,
but whoever they is, they
the folks who actually
do the real voting, after we
do our pretend vote. Yeah!
- Power to the peop--
- Hold the (beeps) on!
You're telling me our votes don't matter?
- Our votes are like suggestions.
- So this November we should,
- Yeah!
- [Men] Dunk the vote!
- These allegations that I have
sent inappropriate pictures
over the internet are
completely ridiculous.
They are levied by my
political rivals who are trying
to embarrass me and
advance their own agenda.
So let me be perfectly clear.
These allegations are false,
and I will be vindicated.
(reporters clamor)
- Tom.
- TMZ has obtained an actual
photo of your genitalia.
They're posting it to
their website As we speak,
they're saying you took
it. How do you respond?
(cameras clicking)
- Okay. I may, I may have sent
one photo of my genitalia.
(reporters clamor)
- Okay, but I, I assure you
that's an isolated incident,
it was a one-time thing.
(reporters clamor)
- Mark. Mark.
- Hey, Senator what about the new report
that there are three new pictures
having been sent to three different women?
(reporters murmur)
- What second rate news
organization is trying to--
- New York Times.
(reporters groan)
- Okay. It was, it was four
total, no more. That was it.
(reporters clamor)
There was four, and no more.
Questions?
- Senator?
- Yes, Amy.
- Yes.
You are sure that there
were only four photos sent?
- That's it four. that's all
there is, no more than four.
- Then how do you explain
the one you sent me?
(reporters gasping)
(reporters chatter)
- Everybody please, please.
I'm begging you.
To forgive me,
for the, the, the foibles
and, and transgressions.
It was the reckless act of a younger man.
- A younger man? You sent it two seconds
before you stepped on stage.
- [Reporter] Senator, Senator
that's very recent.
(reporters clamor)
- Yeah, any, last time I checked,
time is still real, Okay?
So technically speaking,
(phone rings)
I am much older now than it
was all of those seconds ago.
(phones ringing)
(reporters murmur)
- Oh my God. Did I just?
Are you guys?
- Are you getting one too?
- Oh my God, yeah.
- Oh God.
- You get one?
- What?
- What's happening right now?
- I just got one.
- Oh my god,
- What's going on?
I don't understand what's happening.
- [reporter] That's nasty.
- Senator, how are you even doing this?
- You have on proof
that I am doing anything
(reporters gasp)
(cameras click)
- Oh my God!
- I'm sorry,
I'm sorry again.
- Shut up, Senator!
(reporters clamoring)
- I'm sorry.
- I'm sorry again.
I'm sorry one more time.
Oh wait a second, you can
do it but I can't do it?
(reporters clamor)
- [Reporter] Posting it
in the, getting the tape.
(reporters groaning)
- Folks, I have a simple philosophy.
That government should work for everyone,
not just the elite.
And that's why I helped
pass the Farm bill.
Because I care about farmers.
But I won't stop there.
I will work for everyone.
Whether you are young,
whether you are old,
whether you are Asian,
or Hispanic,
whether you are straight
or whether you are gay.
I will work,
for all of you.
And that's why I also
support marriage equality.
Folks, don't choose to be gay,
any more than I, choose be straight.
Could you imagine, if someone told you,
that you couldn't marry
the person that you loved.
Hmm?
I'm sorry. I think gays are people too.
Gays are not different.
Gays,
they are just like us.
They love.
They fear.
They raise their children.
They strive for a better life.
But there are those who
believe that being gay,
is an abomination.
(Paul Brooks scoffs)
That's absurd.
The homosexual community,
is a valuable community in this country.
They are doctors.
They are lawyers.
They are teachers.
They are me.
And they are you.
And their contributions
are no less important
than any other group and
this fine nation of ours.
So,
turn to that gay person
near you,
and see that they are no
different than you are.
Thank you.
(crowd applause)
- It's okay, thank you.
Thank you.
(crowd claps)
- Yes.
- No, no.
- Here's the thing. Here's the thing.
- Okay
- Okay?
I guarantee you. I guarantee you.
If you look at Obamacare
25 years from now,
and you look at the number of enrollees,
in that program
- No, no, no, no, listen, no,
You got it wrong.
- No, please,
by all means, talk
- You got it wrong.
You have to look at the
amount of people enrolled
in the healthcare system
and the tremendous effect
that it has on the economy.
- You're missing the point.
- If you're gonna--
- You are missing the point.
- Oh, am I?
(laughs)
- What you have to do,
what you have to do is look
at the tremendous effect
that Obamacare is having
on the US economy.
And in addition, you have to
look at the government bailouts
of the auto industry
and the banking industry.
- You got it wrong.
You got it wrong.
- I've got it wrong?
So wrong.
You have to look at the effect
on the banking industry,
as well as the auto industry, my friend
- Okay, listen.
- When you do,
- The bottom line,
- No.
- The only conclusion,
- [Both] is that Obama is a disaster.
- [Both] Are you a Republican?
- [Both] Yes.
- I would like to apologize
for this programming mistake.
In the future, we will do better
at choosing our guests.
Here, on Diametrically Opposed.
(lively music)